はい 次のステップというのは
意見が純粋な意見の場合ですよ
感情が入ってない 単なるデータを見て意見を作ったと
そうするとかっこいいでしょうね
でもそちらにも弱点があるんです
ここからは仏陀の立場になりますけどね
で 心は自由になってないんですよ
まず人間の心っていうのは
で 人間に何かの観点 視点
見方 立場からでないとものを見ることはできません
結局は 心は自由じゃないんです
かなりコントロールされているんです
だから我々は何かを見て考えて研究して調べて意見を作っても
それは何かの観点 視点
見方 立場 なんとかのことなんです
から見てしか言えないんです
問題を全体的に全面的に見ることはできないし
しようとしてもそれは不可能です
我々は何か問題を全体的に全面的に見て意見を作るわけじゃないんです
気持ちはありますけど
できないんです だからみんな思ってるだけ
自分の意見はよく考えて調べてもう決めた意見だと思ってるだけなんですけど
本当はこれは不可能なことなんです
自分の意見は何であろうとも
何かの観点から見ているんです
いわゆる何かを眼鏡かけてるんですよ
ということで これは純粋な意見についてそういう弱点があるんです
したがって 純粋な意見にもバイアスが入っている
結局はバイアスが入っている
純粋な意見というのは真理ではなく
部分的な真理ということになる
英語で言えばパーシャルトゥルース
環境も何もなく 客観的に科学者らしくちゃんと調べて意見を作っても
それもやっぱりある観点で見ているんですよ
その人は感情がないんだから嘘を言っているわけじゃないんです
全面的に見てないんです
問題はある部分だけ見るんですよ
かけた眼鏡によって 自分に見えた部分を言うんです
だから真理の一部 ひとかけらなんです
科学の歴史を辿ってみると
よく見事に見えると思います
みんな真理を語っているんじゃなくて
ひとかけらを喋っている
見えたひとかけら それで科学っていうのは
そうやっていろんな科学者が発見した
ひとかけら ひとかけら
ひとかけら 山積みにするんです
全体的な宇宙の生命の真理そのものではありません
だから いつこのひとかけら
ひとかけらつなげて全体像を作るのかっていうことは
これはもう無限大に伸びるでしょうね
だからパーシャルトゥルースと言わなくちゃいけない
これは仏教専門よくありますけどね
お釈迦様の言葉でもよく調べてないです
じゃあ次に行きます それについてお釈迦様のこの面白い冗談の話があります
象さんと目の見えない人々のたとえがあるんですよ
このウダーナワパールの 66 ページにありまして
宗教家たちが自分たちの持論について論争していた出来事に対して
釈尊が目が見えない人々を象というたとえ話を語られたのです
よく考えた意見でさえ
間違ってはないが正しくないということになるのです
難しいことなんですけど
まず この象のたとえ である日
このサーワティという街にあらゆる宗教家の人々を集めたんですよ
これ 珍しいこと 別に会議やったわけじゃないんです
あの 何て言いますか このインテリジェンスシンポジウムあったわけじゃないんです
インテリジェンスって何て言うんですか
学術大会 学術シンポジウム
宗教 あらゆる宗教を集めてやっている
時々やりますけどね 宗教家の学術研究会をやっているわけではなくて
みんな昔の修行者たちが旅ですね
旅人 それで歩いていると
で どこかにすぐ一緒になっちゃうんですね
それでこの季節もありますから
歩く時期と歩けない時期があるんですね
お釈迦様もみんな同じなんですね
雨が降ってくると歩かないんです
3ヶ月とか以上かかっちゃうんです
それから歩き出しちゃうと
どこかで集めてみると
みんないるんですね まるっきり違う違う宗教の人々が
やって ある意味サーワーっていう街で集まっていて
それでもね いろんな宗教の人々はものすごい激しく言い合ってるんですね
ものすごい激しく だから 1箇所で集まるでしょうに
それぞれ自分の宗教の考え方についてものすごい激しいんだそうです
魂があるのかないのかとかね
そんな問題なんで そういうことですよ
それを見て お釈迦様はね
弟子たちがあの宗教家たちがね
もう大変だと もうもう信奉し合っているんだよ
お互いに罵り合って もうもう争論しているんだと
よくあることは このイタミーロサッチャンモーガマンニャン
私が言っていることが正しい宗教である
例えば一人が魂っていうのはある
有限 大きさが決まっていると
人の魂 もう一人の宗教はいい
魂 魂にはスケールが決まることできません
無限大であると お互いに喧嘩するんです
有限という人は そんなことはありえないんだと
一人の魂が無限と言えば
他の人の魂は無限で成り立たんでしょうと
そんな話は と このスペースの中でどうやって魂を置かれますかと
だから私が正しい宗教を教えているんだと
魂は有限 リミットがある
そうすると 広大な宇宙の中で全ての魂はきちんとつけておくことができますと
そんな話で 向こう側は魂は有限といえば
魂っていうのはもう全知全能とかなんと言えなくなるんではないかとかね
普段と何の変わりもないでしょうとかね
あんた方変なこと言ってるんだよとか
それで喧嘩するんです
そこでなんで喧嘩になるのかということ
私が言っていることのみが正しくて
あんた言っていることが完全に間違っているんだという
その一言葉で喧嘩になるんです
それが面白いことに この 2600年前にインドで起きた出来事なんですけど
人間っていうのはものすごいその間で成長したんですよ
それで今も同じことを言って人殺してるんです
どれぐらい成長したかというと
私が信仰している神だけ正しいと
ユダヤ人がジェホバという神だけ正しいと
キリストの人々はキリストが神であると
イスラムの人々はアッラーだけ神であると
人殺し テロ 自爆テロ 何でもやる
だからもう現代人ももう何のこともないんですよ
イスラム教になる場合は
もう大体 1分以内でイスラム教徒になります
一旦なったら 絶対他の宗教は聞いてはいけない
勉強してはいけない 絶対宗教改宗してはいけない
それからは人生は終わりということで
イスラムも知識にはきちんと釘をつけておくんです
で もうだんだん 文章を３つ４つぐらいあって
それは言うだけ 私はアッラーのみ絶対的な神様であり
そうして信じると 他の神様は絶対信じませんと
またありますけど まあ覚えるぐらいの価値がないんだから覚えてないんですけど
どうしても必要というならば調べます
で まあそんなもんで喧嘩になるんですよ
自分の意見が正しい そこでお釈迦様に行ったら
お釈迦様がちょっと物語を言うんですよ
比丘たちは昔々 このサーワティ町にある王様がいたんだと
この王様が自分のこの町に
サーワティ町にいる目が見えない人々はみんな宮殿の前に集めてもらったんだと
集めてもらって 王様の象を一頭そちらに連れてきて
で 君たちはこの象を見て
そう 象っていうのはどういうものかと私に言ってくれと
そこでみんなサーッと行って
もうそこを触ってみるんですよ
みんな一人一人触ってみる
触ったのは出て行きなさいと
もう追い出されるし あんた触った？はい
悪いなと 目が見えないんだから触るしかね
方法ないでしょうし みんなもう触って触って触って出て行って
それでみんなまとめたんです
集めてもらって では象っていかがでしょうかと聞いたら
自分が触った触ったもののことをしゃべるんですよ
象っていうのはなんか箒と似ているんだよと一人が言うんですよ
おっぽのを触っちゃって
なんか箒みたいですねと
それでもう一人がこの足を触った人が
あれはちょっと ちょっと大きなうすっていうのは
大体あの大きさですよ
インドでも自分の国にもある
うすは日本であるような
この手で持ってあれはないんです
あ 象っていうのは臼と似ているんだよ
もう一人が もう一人がもう体を触ってみる
これってなんかでっかい山みたいやと
で 鼻を触った方がなんか月の形しているんだと
耳を持った人がなんかのもみ殻
え？実と言うんですか
籾殻を分離する あの あります
耳の形ですけどね それと似ているんだと
実と似ているんだという
これでこの王様に報告しなくちゃいけないでしょ？嘘言ったらあかんでしょ
それで互いにギャーギャーギャーギャー喧嘩し始めたんだと
あんたなんてことを言おうとしているんですか？と
象っていうのは箒と似ているんではないんでしょうかね
これこそ絶対的な真理である
山みたいと もっての他
そんな考え よくもそんな考え方を思ったもんやと
だって本人がおっぽしか触ったことないんだから
いや こんなものに山というバカがいるのかと
これ 足が触った人から
これはどう見たって臼と似ているんではないかと
箒ってどうやってこれ触って箒と言えるのかと
いうことで 互いにむちゃくちゃもう喧嘩したんだと
の話をするんです で 王様が
ただ つまらなかったら退屈でしたでしょうね
王様は一応 だから王様がすごくニコニコと笑っていたんだ
こいつの喧嘩を見て そのように
この宗教家たちだからみんな真剣
真面目なんですよ 自分の修行から勉強からいたった結論は言ってますよ
しかし お釈迦様が言うのは
それ全部 あの目が見えない人々の意見と変わりはありませんと
ということは全体的に見てないということなんです
それは見る能力はないんですよ
目が見えないという例を持ってきたのは
そういうわけなんですよ
必要なのは目なんですよ
この人の目というものはないんですね
その人の認識手段は触れることなんですね
そこで心が自由でない
完全じゃないということを言いたがっているんです
我々は自分持っている手段で知ろうとする
でもそれじゃなくてもう一つ目が必要なんですよ
目さえあれば あの人の目が見えない人々には
象そのものを見えるんですよ
触る必要もないんです
それだったら誰一人も互いに喧嘩もしない
だから すごい象徴的な例え話です
だから 目という一言はすごい象徴的なんですね
これが我々 何かに対して意見を述べる時は
我々にあるべき何かないんですよ
物事を全体的に見るために必要な何かないんですよ
欠けてるんです 原理主義精神ではダメです
それがお釈迦様が言ってる悟りというか
智慧というか そういうことなんです
我々の頭の中でどういうふうに考えていっても
これが目が見えない人々の
これは真面目な人の場合ですよ
単なる妄想で感情でいうことはもう全然気にしない
仏教はきちんと論理的に
理性に基づいて データに基づいて意見を述べても混乱するになる
パーシャルトゥルースだけ
嘘を言ってるわけじゃないんだ
だから この言ってるのはよく考えた意見でさえ
間違ってはないが正しくないんですよ
だから箒のようと言ったのは間違ってないんですよ
象の尾っぽは箒と似ているんだから
触ったことないでしょ
尾っぽは あの毛はすごいきついんですよ
かなり硬いな 針金みたい
だからあの箒やとすごい元気な
もう若い もう象だったら結構毛がしっかりあるんですよ
年取ってくるとまあ折れたりもいろいろありますけどね
だからこの そういうことになるんです
自分の意見が正しいと固く信じると
他人との対立が生じる
そういうわけで 我々には何かあるはずのものが無い
これ 智慧の目がないんです
あるのは六根だけ 一般の世界だったら五根だけだと言ってますけど
一応心というものでは考えたりはする
しかし 何かがないんですね
だから自分の意見 正しいと固く信じちゃうと
どうしても他の人とぶつけて対立はする
ですから 世界に調和も平和もないのです
だから事実を見てください
我々生きている世界に
歴史の中で一度でも平和があったことは
調和があったことはないでしょう
とにかくお互いに対立する
動物の時代から石器時代から今も何のことない
対立 対立 戦い だから戦い
対立 戦争 テロ行為などは普通ですよ
こんな誰が踏ん張って世界平和築こうと言ったってできるわけないんですよ
成り立ちません これからに
こんなもんです 世界は
昔もそんなもんです というのは
あるあるべきではなくてね
あってほしい 何て言いますか
とても大事な何かがないんですね
智慧の目ということ はい
次に行きます  はい その経典の最後に
お釈迦様はこういう偈を歌ってるんです
イメースキラサッジャンティーケーサマナブラームナ
ヴィッガイヘナンヴィワダンティージャナーエーカンガダッシーノ
イメースキラサッジャンティ
イメースっていうのは
これらに足が引っ張られているって
これらというのはあらゆる意見
宗教的な考え方 神がいるという人はいいし
いないという人がいるし
死後があるという人がいるし
ありませんという人がいるし
もうあらゆる宗教対立がありましてね
そういうものについて人々は引っ張られ
引っかかっているんですよ
エーケーサマナブラフマンの一部のシャモンバラモンたちは
なんで一部でしたんですかというと
ブッダはそこには引っかかってないんだから
ブッダの弟子たちも引っかかってないんです
ブッダと弟子たち以外はみんな引っかかっているんだよと
ヴィッガイヘナンヴィワダンティ
自分たちの意見に固執して論争するんだと
ヴィッガイヘナンヴィワダンティというのは
彼らが固執して我こそ正しいということにして
もう論争する ジャナーエーカンガダッシーノ
ジャナー この人々はエーカンガダッシーノ
一つの側面しか見てないんだと
いわゆる一つのものしか見てないということが偏見と訳しましたけど
偏見を持っているんだからね
ある一つの立場から見ている
それだけ それが全てだと勘違いする
だからそれに固執しちゃいますからね
固執しなきゃ大丈夫ですのにね
論争するから はい では進みます
で 次のところ 社会人に興味あるポイント
えーと  これから仏教のことはちょっと置いておいて
普通の社会人にちょっと興味があるポイントをいくつか出します
それがこの このテーマを作った
提供した人の考え方そのままそれから移ります
これが文章 私の文章ではありません
テーマは提供した人の考え方です
意見が違う場合の対処法
ちょっとカットしたんですけどね
二人の何でしたっけ？二人の人の行動方針で意見が食い違った場合
1 自分の意見で説得して納得してもらい
自分の意見を通す  2 相手の意見に納得できれば相手の意見を通す
3 両者の意見を混ぜ合わせて第三の意見にまとめる
それぞれの意見を尊重し
別 別行動 単独行動をとる
その 4 つを私に出されて
私は仏教ではどんな答え出すのかというチャレンジですけど
それで仏教の答え これはまあ 1 は強引押しつける行為です
これ 一緒にやった方が読みやすいんですけど
理解しやすいんですけど
2 は弱気者の立場  1 ってのは自分の意見通すことでしょ
強引ですね それが で 強引に納得してもらって
自分の意見を通す そうすると
1 というのは強引ですね
2 番目は相手の意見に納得できれば相手の意見を通すこと
それで 2 番目の答えは
えーと これは弱気者の立場ですよ
3 番目は混ぜることなんですね
両者の意見を混ぜ合わせて
第三の意見にまとめるということ
それで 3 番目はどういうことかというと
えーと  3 は誰でも行おうとする行為だが
これは誰でもやろうとするんですよ
お互いに意見が食い違ってますから
なんとかまとめましょうとかね
みんなやろうとするんですよ
うまくいくはずはありません
これはうまくいかないんですよ
意見が食い違った場合は
じゃあまとめましょうと
みんなもうやろうとするんですよ
しかし うまくいかないです
まとめませんよ だって
自分の意見から見れば
相手の意見が正しくないでしょうに
自分が正しい意見を持っていて
妥協しようとすることが半分間違った意見を取れることでしょう
それ嫌じゃないんですか？だからうまくいかないんですよ
相手の意見が良くないと知っているのに妥協している
これはだからうまくいかない
四っていうのはもう単独行動ですね
これが それぞれの意見を尊重して単独行動すると
まあまあ 四はわがまま
まあ勝手なことですね
結局は じゃああんたはあなたのやり方やってください
私のやり方やるぞと これでは成長も発展もないんですよ
例えば自分の意見に何か間違ったところあったらわからないでしょう
勝手な単独行動するんだから
そんな生き方は全然成長も発展も何もない
より優れた意見が現れるということはあり得ないんですね
だから単独行動もダメなんですよ
平和も調和も期待できない
その場合はみんな単独行動で
大変によくないんですよ
結局は ４つもよくないんです
自分の意見を通すことも
相手の意見に納得してそれに乗り移ることも
お互いに意見を合わせて何かに何かをすることも
単独行動もどちらでもできん
私の方針も相手の方針も置いておく
だから答えは私の方針
私の考え意見というのは置いておく
これはあなたのそれも置いておく
置いておいて 客観的に可能な限りの方針を二人で提供する
まず 一つの意見が分かりました
もう一つ意見ないんでしょうか
もう一つないんでしょうか
じゃあ二人でも考えられる限り
あらゆる意見を出して
一つデータバンクを作りましょうと
そういうことをしなくちゃいけないんですね
で そこから意見を作る
もう自分の意見じゃない
もうデータバンクだからね
相手の意見でもないんですよ
可能な限り意見出して出してデータバンクを作る
作ってからそこはまあまあ二人で見ましょうか
見る時のポイントは単純ですよ
利益が最大 損は最小という
ポイントで 1個 1個 1個 1個取ってみる
そうすると何か発展できると思います
ああ こういう風な意見だったら
利益は最大で損は最小やと
言うと 二人でそれ行動すればいいでしょう
誰も負けたわけでも何ともない
二人も大変楽しいんですよ
いいことを見つけましたと
いい考え方を見つかりました
これがやり方なんですよ
本当は誰もやってないんだけど
意見の場合は よろしいですか？すげ抜きますか？まあ
これちょっと覚えておいた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
このやり方はね 会社でもどこでも実行できますよ
一人の人が意見を出しても
それだけでは足りませんよと
もっともっといろんな意見を出してくれと
たとえバカバカらしい意見でもいいんだよと
通るわけねえぞと思う意見でも大丈夫だよ
全部出しましょうと 可能な限り
言うと何の遠慮もなく言えるでしょうに
私はこう思います で 言って座っちゃうと
もうそれではもううまくいかないんですね
だからもう自分がちょっと真剣になっちゃって
なんとか通してもらえるように言わなくちゃいけないとかね
批判されなくされないように言わなくちゃいけないとか
いろいろ思うんでしょうね
だからとにかくこの たとえバカバカらしい笑えるほどの意見であろうとも
もう思えるほど全部出しましょうと
まあ現代でこのブレーンストーミングとかなんとか言って
あんまりいいこといい言葉ではないんですけどね
もういい あまりも なんであんな言葉っていうのは
すごく好きじゃないんですけどね
そういうことで それからもうデータベースですからね
誰でも関係ないんです
そこから損得論理でいくんです
はい 次に行きます 次の質問ですね
真理と見解 意見の食い違いや見解の相違が起きるのは
そこに真理がないからという話を聞きました
これは私の話ですけどね
どうしても意見のすり合わせ
統一を図らなければならない時
なんとか真理を発見して
全員が納得するためには何に注意したら良いでしょう
これは日本人書いた文章だから一応意味がわかるでしょう
わからないのは次に来る私の文章なんです
こういう質問ですね こちらで言いたいのはね
意見の食い違いがあると
どちらか間違っていると私が言っているのではないかと
これはまずいんだから
なんとか正しい意見でね
いきたいんだけど どうすればいいかってことですね
ちょっとものすごい ものすごい難しい
複雑な質問なんですよ
はい 次に行きます これ
仏教の答え 意見の食い違いになっただけでも
どちらでも正しくないがないか
誰かわかってないかという 2つ
そのどちらかですね 意見は食い違ったということは
どちらでは間違っている
あるいは誰かが分かってない
もし一人が正しければ
相手が分かった どちらかなんですよ
しかし 一人が真理を言っているならば
異論が成り立たないはずです
意見が食い違い場合でも
一人が真理を言っているんだったら
食い違いにはならないのです
もう例えばね 地球が丸いという時は異論はありません
言っていることを真理だから
だから私は言うんですよ
異論がある場合は 食い違いの場合はお互いさん間違ってるんだよ
だから世の中にある意見というのは必ずしも違う意見もあるでしょ
だから一切意見 全て間違ってます
何のこともないです なるがいね
観点 視点 傾向 偏見 バイアスなどがなどバイアスがなくては意見が成り立たないんですよ
何か観点がなければ意見が成り立たないんでしょう
心は不完全です 意見もだから意見も不完全です
誰でも意図的に間違っていることを述べるのではない
ただ正しくないだけ 誰も意図的に嘘を言おうとしてるわけじゃないんですよ
みんな自分の観点で見ているだけのことです
だから 象の例えはすごく役に立つんですよ
誰も嘘を言ってるわけじゃないんだけど
正しくないんでね 残念なことに
だから この意見食い違いの場合はそういうことなんですね
真理に至る方法っていうのは
はい 次に行きます 意見は間違ったとは言えないが
正しくはないということに注意するのです
だから 意見食い違ったら真理に近寄りたいと思う人は
このポイントを覚えておけば大丈夫ですよ
間違ってはとは言えないが
正しくはないということ
で 皆様に覚えやすくわかりやすく英語にしたんです Concerning
any opinions one must one must maintain the attitude not
wrong but not perfect.
not wrong but not perfect. ということを覚えておけば
まあなんとかなります
この仕方で真理を発見できると言い切れないが
皆が納得できる結論には至れる
こういうあのポイントを覚えておけば
この質問にあったのは
どうやってみんな納得して
なんかいい方法ないのかということですから
だから相手の意見に対しても間違ってはないんですけど
パーフェクトではない
私の意見も間違ってはないんだけど
という立場で話し合うと
まあなんとか納得できる答えが来るんですよ
対立はなくなる 完全に調和と平和が保たれます
こんなやり方だけでは真理を発見できるということはちょっと言いづらいんですよ
だって このひとかけら
ひとかけら ひとかけら
発見してもしても全体像は言えないと思いますよ
だから やっぱり何かが欠けているものが現れてこない限りはね
智慧の目が真理には至れないんです
これであの質問に対する仏教の答え
またあったような気がします
質問は 次の質問は 仏教の決議は全員一致
以前に先生のお話の中で
仏教の決議は基本的に全員一致であるというところに引用しているんですね
ということが出てきました
最悪 多数決になる場合でも
多数決の結果に従う 多数決を行うことに賛成するという一致だけはしなければいけないという話でした
なぜ仏教では全員一致を目指すのでしょうか
ということ 仏教は全員一致を目指す
どうしても最悪の場合だけ
多数決にするというね
それはもうできるだけ避けたいということなんです
それに仏教の答えすぐにできます
仏教の答え 全員一致とは
その行動方針は正しいということです
全員一致ということは
その行動方針というのは正しい
だからみんなもう異論なし
こうしましょうと ほかにないんだよということなんです
だから仏教の世界では
常に正しい行為 正しい行動は厳密
もうよくです だから仏教の時に出家世界ではもう善人一致でなければいけません
善人一致っていうことは正しいっていうことが単純といえば
それは世界の人類一致というより
ある特定の社会組織の会員のことです
人類全員みんな一致でくれるという話って
ちょっと成り立たない
実践性はない 実効性はない
だから社会っていうのは小さな小さな小さなセルでしょ
そのそのセルの中で グループの中で全員一致です
例えばある  組合を作る
ある目的で組合を作るんだから
その人々の人生すべてじゃないんですよ
労働組合っていうのは
自分の人生 何から何まで家庭内の問題まで解決するわけじゃないでしょう
労働組合は労働に関する問題に関わるだけですからね
だから ある目的で組織を作る
そこで善人一致っていうのは
その組織が正しい行動をしているということなんです
それから 善人一致の場合は皆平等
誰の権利も侵害しないということになるんです
ある会社である組織で
ある協会であるグループで全員一致になる場合は
誰の権利も侵害していない
みんな平等ですというブッダが教えるあの言葉が機能しているんです
人間の社会では全然そんなこと見えませんだけどね
だからみんな あの 何といいますか
多数決で言っちゃいますけど
これでみんな平等というわけじゃないんですよ
結構権利は侵害されます
また その組織は平和で穏やかで
活動するだけでなく だけではなく
長生きもするのです 善人一致の組織は長生きします
潰れません 簡単に だからその初期仏教ほど世界から攻撃を受けた組織はありませんよ
いまだに元気です 今 自分の国も津波が起きても大変ですけど
その中でも仏教は過ごしてあるそうで
かなりもう牙を出しても行動してますけど
潰せませんと思いますけどね
昨日も二人そういう話ずっと話してまた喋ってはいたんですけどね
いろんなところでやっていることとか
でもやっぱり潰れないと思いますね
善人一致主義はもう大事にする
それからこの世界 人類にそれは関係ないんですよ
組織に社会に関係ある
社会で今小さいです 例えば日本という社会ではありませんよ
皆様一人一人には自分の社会があるんです
会社の仲間たちやら家庭やら友達たちやら
自分がその社会で生きているんです
日本全国で生きているわけじゃないんです
だから それは自分の社会
そこで善人一致の生き方をしなくちゃ
だから我々はいつでも管理できる小さな世界にいるんですよ
巨大な社会に生きるということはあり得ない
不可能です 例えば日本の総理大臣にしても
日本全国を支配しているんだからって
日本全国相手にできるわけじゃないんです
彼の周りにいる何人かなんです
その人々と毎日会って
話し合って 連絡を取って
どうすればよろしいかと
それで決めるんです それは小泉総理大臣の社会なんです
結構小さいとは思いますけど
大きいんだったら管理できないんです
誰でもそういうことなんです
日本の象徴かもしれません
だけど 天皇陛下は本人の具体的な社会はすっごく小さいんです
こびかすは我々よりはちょっと大きいかもしれませんだけど
もうでも小さいんです
管理できる そういうふうなことで
どんな人間でもある小さなソサエティの中で生きていますから
その中で善人一致に生きてみなさいよと
そうするとみんな平等で
みんなの権利を侵害することなく
平和で長生きするでしょう
で なんで人類に対して言わないのかというと
お釈迦様の教えは人類ではなくて
生命に対する真理なんですよ
それが地球が丸いというように
誰にも何も言うことをできない
もう頑固たる絶対的な真理なんです
ブッダ言うのは だからそれ人間にわかるわけないでしょ
あのもう一つないんだから
あの必要な智慧の目っていうものはないんだから
だからお釈迦さん言ってます
みんな自分の偏見というところで
ちょっとひとかけらだけ真理をね
なめてるだけであると
だからそういう人々には像の全体像は見えません
しかし 像は誰も言っていることではなくて
別なものなんですけど
過去人は嘘を言っているわけではない
だから その像っていうのはもう箒みたいなものやと言ったら
そのグループはそこで全員一致になっちゃえばいいじゃないんですか
別な解説を そういうことで
この真理はみんないっぺんに堂々と認めてくれるわけじゃない
だから それをよく知った上で伝道活動したんです
認めない 反対されるということは当たり前ですから
だから認めない ない 反対するということは
全然お釈迦様に対しては
ああ 困ったな せっかく私は喋ったのに認めてないとかね
それはあり得ないんです
で 私と違ってお釈迦様は自分でわざわざ出て喋ったりしないんですよし
相手から聞くんですね
現代の皆様と違って 昔の人々はよく質問するんですからね
現代人はね 知識がありすぎちゃって
脳細胞は使ってないんですね
あれはなんか なんですかね
放送をするための頭蓋骨の中
何か溜め込めなきゃいけないということに溜め込んでいるかはわかりませんだけど
使った方がいいんだと思いますけど
だからバシバシと質問すると
質問するたびに意見は潰れますよ
仏教に当たると でもそれで真理には至る
新しい考え方が入ってくる
新しい見解が出てくる
視野が広がっていく だから
そのままでいたい場合は
一番黙っているのは楽なんですよ
質問は何もしない だから昔の人々はそうじゃなくて
あまり本もなかったし
だから人に会ったらもうとにかくあれこれと聞かないと
そういうことはあった
だからお釈迦様の場合は結構楽でしたんですよ
すぐ相手が自分の意見を言うんだから
また言いたこと言いたくてたまらんでしょうしね
相手はお釈迦様の意見もないし
それでそのその道を通して
その人に真理に目覚めてもらうことをするんです
そういうことで はい それに行きます
また 仏教の答えは続けています
多数決になると一部が納得しないことは明らかです
例えば 全員一致ではなく
多数決の場合は一部はもう納得してないんですよ
その一部の意見は尊重しないことになるのです
ある小さな組織の中で一部の意見はまるっきり使わない
多数決の場合 これは多数派の暴力とも言えるものです
これ民主主義でないんですよ
多数決はただの暴力なんです
多数派の暴力 暴力 多数決の場合は少数派に対して謝るぐらいの配慮でも必要ですよ
どうしても最悪の場合は投票して多数決になったら
反対投票した人々に本当に深々とお謝った方がいいんですよ
申し訳ございませんと
皆様のご意見はまあもう使用できませんということになりましたと
謝るぐらい必要でしょう
一人もやってないでしょ
それで民主主義だと謳っていること
暴力主義です 真理を重んじる
組織の繁栄を重んじる少数派なら
多数決を素直に受け止めて持論を捨てるのです
世間ではこれも見えない現象です
例えば ある組織の中で異論が成り立ったって
もう投票しなくちゃいけないんですね
というか ボート取らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
それでボート取らなくちゃいけないんだから
やっぱりもう多数決めちゃうでしょう
それで自分たちが負け方する
少数派が しかし その少数派の人々も
この組織の繁栄をものすごい真剣に考える
みんなのことを本当に心配している
とにかく我々はうまく繁栄して成長していきたいのではないでしょうか
そういう優しさがあるんだったら
負けた瞬間がこういう風に決めましたから
はい わかりました では
みんなこの意見でいきましょうと
すぐその決めた意見に入れ替えるのです
我々の意見が無視された
私に対して あの人 あの人
あの人反対しましたとかね
無名の投票でも ちゃんと手書きの形にしてやろうかな
どうです どこどうですどうですから
私に反対したのはとかね
それぐらい気持ち悪いことやってるんですよ
その場合 その人々の組織の繁栄ではなくて
自分個人の繁栄を考えているんですよ
一番いい例というのは
国会みたいな政治家の世界
国の繁栄ではなくて 自分の党の繁栄を考えている
で 最悪多数決になった場合は
少数派が本当にその国の
その組織の その会社の繁栄幸せを思う立派な人だったら
判決出た瞬間ではい わかりました
ではみんなでやりましょうということになるんです
それでまた全員一致になるはずなんです
でも その現象もこの世の中ではない
謝るぐらいもしないし
負けた方が じりじりと賛成するということもしないですね
はい そうです では また質問ですね
意見を主張する正しい方法
何かを協議するとき 自分の信じた意見をしっかり素直に自信とも率直に自信を持って述べて賛同を得たい場合
どんな注意点がありますか
その場の雰囲気や反対勢力に負けて納得できないまま
これ何でしたっけ？えっ？屈服しないためにはどうすればよいでしょうか
はい それで仏教の答え
率直に自分率直に自信
何でしたっけ この自信じゃないんです
率直に自信を持って述べない意見は大した意見ではありません
まず どうやって率直に自信を持って言えないんだったら
ろくな意見じゃないんですよ
すごい大事な意見だったら自信を持って言えるでしょう
そちらに着点があるんですよ
言いたいんだけど どういうか教えてちょうだいとかね
そんなに言えないのだったらやめなさいと
よく答えがない 私の答えは
言う自信がないだったらやめなさい
ろくな意見じゃないでしょ
どうするっていうことになる
感情に汚染されているか
弱気で相手の気持ちを重んじるふりをしているかでしょう
自分の意見に感情が入っていて
それで弱気になって言えなくなったと
それあるいはやっぱり相手の気持ちも重んじなくちゃいけないから
大嘘をついているか どちらかなんです
賛同してほしい 納得してほしいと思う人は
わがままか経験不足ですね
自分の意見に賛同してほしいと思ったら
よっぽど経験不足 青いんですよ
もう 冗談じゃない あるいはあまりにもわがままで子供みたい
子供はどうしても自分の意見に賛同してもらうんだから
親に 決して負けません
親なんか これ明らかに子供のわがままでしょうに
勝ったんだからって そちらが正しいわけないでしょう
だからその気持ちを捨ててほしい
自分の意見が立派な意見だったら
堂々と言う 賛同しようがそんなのは勝手やと
知ったもんではありませんということにしないと
却下されても知ったものじゃない
どうしても賛同してほしいなら
粘り強く 異論はあるかもしれませんが
お願いしますという運動をすることですよ
これ冗談じゃないんですよ
どうしても自分の意見を通してほしい
その場合はだから認めません
そうではない そんなこと言わんじゃなくて
自分の意見を言って どうかお願いします
お願いしますとかね 頭下げて下げてお願い運動するしかないんですよ
この世の中 これ結構いい方向に行くんですよ
そうすると たとえ自分の意見がね
それほど立派でなくても賛同して実行できます
これ偉そうに納得してやる
そうありえないんですよ
まず意見を言ってから
みんないろいろ 皆様方はいろいろ異論ながら
反対の気持ちはあるかもしれませんけど
どうかこの点でお願いいたします
で 必死になって結構運動をやるんです
お願いします 運動 そうすると賛同してくれます
はい で 意見の述べ方ですね
次に 我々はどのように我々の意見を述べればよろしいかと
まず頭の中で整理整頓することですね
興奮してすぐ存じに行っちゃうんじゃなくて
次に感情を完全に断ち切る
理性的になる これ 私の意見という気持ちを捨てる
こういう意見があると客観的にするんです
感情は断ち切る 理性で
結論に意見に至った過程で
自分が参照してしたデータを順番に示しながら
その都度相手がどのように思うかと聞いてみる
やはり自分の意見を喋る前に整理整頓して
客観的に理性的なこのポイントを見て
いきなり意見を言うんじゃなくて
この意見に意見を作るために作ったデータ
参照したデータあるでしょう
そこをその順番で言うんです
まず一つのデータを言って説明して
この場合は皆様はどうどう思いましょう
んでしょう 思いますかと
そこで聞いてくる そうすると
それはこういうことではね
みんな思っちゃうんですよ
で 次のデータを言う 言って
皆様はこの場合はどう思いますか？と
次のデータを言う では
この場合も皆様どう思いますか？そうやってこの全体的な結論に至るに意見は言わない
これ過程で納得してもらうんです
最後のデータと調整するときは
自分が言わなくても相手が同じ結論に至るんです
自分で言う必要ないんです
意見は そうするとみんな自動的にあの意見に立ってるんです
そういうやり方ですよ
これはお釈迦様のやり方で
そういうやり方なんです
いつでもこのあなたはどう思いますか？と
例えば無我だよと言わないんです
あんたね この肉体はあんたどう思いますかね
変わらないものだと 壊れないものだと思ってますかと
ったら いい お釈迦様 肉体はもう年取るわ
変わるわ壊れるわ じゃあ変われる壊れるものだったら
永不滅とは言えますかね
いえいえ 変われる壊れる
永不滅さて 言えないんだよと
相手が言ってるんです
ブッダじゃないんです
そこで変われて壊れて腐り腐っていくものはね
私です 私の魂ですと執着するべきものですかね
とんでもないんですよ
お釈迦様 そんなことは
では この環境 感覚どうですかね
痛いとか楽しい 気持ち悪いとかね
痒いとかね それっていうのは変わらない
永不滅なものでしょ とんでもない
当然変わりますから では
その変わるもの 壊れるものっていうのを自分で魂ですと執着できますか？とんでもない
お釈迦様 そうやって色受想行識まで言っていくんですよ
それで結局 お釈迦様おっしゃってる
全部全部無我ですよと
執着に値しないよと 結論に相手が至ってるんです
お釈迦様は自分の意見はボーンと出さないんです
それはブッダの方法です
きれいに整理整頓して
データを順番に持っていく
すごい順番 この小さな小さな順番で相手から答え
相手の答え 相手の意見をいただく
で 最後に相手の意見をまとめて相手にあげる
これはあなたの意見ですよ
これで OK です これが意見を正しく述べる方法でもあるし
相手に賛同してもらう方法でもあります
覚えておけば これっていうのはすごいことですけどね
えーと あなたはどのように思いますか？とは大事なポイントです
私はこう思いますではなくて
あなたはどのように思いますか？と
どういう質問というところは一番大事なんです I
必須も I assume I think とかね
とんでもないです だから経典をさらさらと読んでみてください
それではあなたはどう思いますか？という言葉はよくよく出てきます
ポイントを相手が出した時でも
相手がポイントを出す
結論を出す 意見を出す場合は
お釈迦様はではあなたに質問します
あなたは好きなように答えてくださいと言って
順番に質問するんです
この場合はあなたはどう思いますか？と
この場合はどう思いますか？と
最後の質問になってくると
相手が言った意見は全く潰れてるんです
だからそれは全然相手の気付きは感じないんですよ
びっくりするんですよ
よく目覚めてくれたんだと
自分を侮辱することもなく
けなすことこともなく
否定することもなく 見事に
だからあのいつも経典の最後にあるでしょ
あの文章は だから具体的な起きた出来事は
このテープレコーダーで記録するような感じでないんだから
全部文章にして暗記できる
レイアウトにあるんだから
ちょっと本当かなという感じがあるかもしれない
そうじゃないんですよ
だからそういうふうに言ったんです
そうすると最後に質問になってくると
相手が質問してきた人が驚いてびっくりして
よく目覚めてくれましたと
暗闇の中に灯火をつけてくれたような感じだと
お釈迦様 素直に喜べるんですよ
それが意見の述べ方です
はい またあります 賛成するためのデータではなく
自分の意見に反対するならば
どのようなところでしょうかと先に問いかけておく
これは仏教的というよりも
俗世間のね 自分たちが何か自分が意見
例えば研究する 研究して結論を出す場合は
この結論に反対する意見もあるでしょうかと自分自身に調べるんですよ
それだったらどう答えればよろしいか
うん 大体よくあることで
みんな研究したりデータを取ったりすると
この都合の悪いデータは見くっとに捨てる
都合のいいポイントだけ取るんですよ
テレビで行って取材することと同じで
都合のいいところだけ
街でインタビューなんかするでしょ
だからテレビ局がそれに反対だったら
100人聞いたらもう二人ぐらい反対したならば
それだけ出すんですよ
だってごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ言う
あの 98人ののはもう放送しない
文句も言えないんだから
時間ないんだから  5分の番組であんたどう思いますかね？たった 30 秒しかないんだよ
このケップを流すために言うんです
そういうふうなことで
都合のいいところしか出さないんですね
世の中 それで皆様方も
我々どんな人間でも そういうマインドセット
メンタルセットアップなんですか
え？この頭のセットアップ
どういうそのマインドセットアップだから
心がそういう風にできているんだからね
気づかないんですよ 都合のいいことだけ聞いて
他は聞いてないっていう
勇気があれば 反対データも自分で提供して
それに応える 例えば 自分が発表している時は
もうデータを出して発表しながら反対データも出す
この私のこの意見については
こういうこういうポイントがございまして
これではこれは反対ですと
しかし 私はこういう風に見ているんだから
それは置いておこうと
こういう風に言った方が
相手の人々にはどうすることもできなくなるんですよ
相手の自尊心 態度を決して潰さないこと
それもすごい大事なんです
自分が何か自分の意見
強引に押し付けをしているでしょうに
それ自体も大変な侮辱行為だから
かなり気をつけないとね
この相手の気持ちとか
どんなそんなことじゃないんですよ
あの自尊心を潰したらいけないんです
だから前言った この人の気持ちも尊重してとかね
あんなのはもう物事若手の人が言ってるうわことで
仏教というのはそれ相手の自尊心だけは潰さない
意見なんかは片っ端から片っ端に潰してもいいんですよ
どうせ葉っぱ 1枚のぐらいの意見だから
しかし 自尊心は生命は平等だからね
よく自尊心潰すところを皆さんはわからないんだから
次の行で書いたんです
最初からあなたは怒るかもしれませんが
反対するかもしれませんがとか言うでしょ
私もよく言うんですよ
みんなすごい丁寧に敬語で
先生はまあもうもう反対するのは決まっているんだから
あれというのは侮辱そのもの
丸ごと侮辱なんですよ
私はどんな反応するかで私の勝手でしょう
なぜそこまで管理しようとするんですかね
人の意見を侮辱しようか
認めようか 受け取ろうかというのは
その個人の自由でしょう
最初からも丁寧ということをかぶって
あ 先生はまあまあおそらく反対するかもしれませんよとかね
それでも切れてるんです
はい あの一言葉で意見は聞かない
聞いてやることもしない
結局負けですよ 最初から負けをくれたんだから
自尊心 それではなくても
時々子供とかいうわがままでも言いたいことを言っちゃう
すごい効いてある だからこの私たち大人がよくやりますよ
忙しいところ申し訳ございませんが
電話でだったらかけるなよ
それも本気で思ってるんだったら
話早く終わるでしょ ではポイントでこういうことですけどとか
大事なことありますけど
大事なことなら別に忙しいところ申し訳ないっていうことはないでしょう
それで延々と喋るんですよ
それっていうのは自尊心
だから相手は丁寧な適切な返事はもらわなくなります
だから私にはそれ見えてるんだから
何のこともなくできますけど
権利することも そんなことを気にする
どうせそんなもんだよ
それでもやりませんよ
いくらこのポイント知ってる私でさえもやらないんだから
世間ではそんなに期待しない方がいいんです
私は結構ブッダのやり方と物事にとらわれない手段方法とかね
もう長い間の人生だから知ってます
それでも向こうは法律間違っちゃうともう
受け取られません そういうことだから
そこ世間ではね 期待しない方がいい
だからすごい気をつけて
相手の自尊心を 潰してはいけない
まあ時々あのひとつはお願い事
約束 キャンユードゥーミーアフェバー
英語で言えばね いきなりそこを説得されて
何をするようなか それはわからないでしょうに
だから英語で言えば キャンユードゥーミーアフェバー
イフイットイズリーズナブルと答えなくちゃいけないんですよ
私にちょっとお願い事がありますけど
それはもうリーズナブルであるならば
リーズナブルはそれでいいでしょう
それなりに対応できることであるならばという風に言った方がいいんですよ
何頼むかわからへんから
よくあります 最初からもう約束させちゃう
それから物事を言うんです
それも自尊心を潰すことなんで
そういうことで人間がね
かなりくじけないんですよ
約束したんですけど 果たせないんだから
後から見ると 例えばお母さん
私のこと好きですか？好きですよ
お前のことなら だったら私言うことなら聞くでしょ
もう聞きますよと だったらこれこれやってくれと
これでお母さんが信頼できません
約束破るとかね まあ約束したんではないかと
椅子どいて だいたい家族の中でね
小さな子供と母親の間でそういうことよくあるでしょう
我々がそれ大人になってやっているのは情けないんです
ある子供が私に意見聞いて
犬が飼いたくて で 親は反対だと
ところで とにかくもう子供っていうのは負けず嫌いし
とにかく親に勝つという気持ちはすごくあるんだからね
で 私に言うんですよ 私はね
一生のお願いだからと
今回お願いしたいと思ってますよ
先生どう思いますか？と
ちっちゃな子供でしたけど
その時は それで何のことか
すぐ繰り返して あのね
それだけは言わないでくれと
親に すぐわかったんです
一生のお願い それだけは言わないでくれ
と言って さらに納得するために
あなたはね まだ子供で親からお願いすることはたったそれだけだと思ってるんですか？と
それからずっといろんなことをお願いしなくちゃいけないでしょう
だから その次の場を置いておきなさいよと
これからの無数に数え切れないほどのことをお願いできる
この何て言いますか その権利をね
でも我々 平気で言うと一生のお願いだからとかね
ああいうことはよくないんですよ
最初にももうそんなもう余計な条件に言って
嘘の条件に言って 人を騙して強引になんとかやってもらいたくなる
それで相手の自尊心も潰れるんですよ
親子であろうとも平等ですよ
会社でもどこでも 犬も猫も人間もみんな生命として平等です
そこはすごい大事なポイントで
だから自尊心だけは潰せないようにしなくちゃいけない
だから意見の述べ方の場合も
そういうポイントは気をつけるんです
はい まあすぐ終わりましょう
意見の述べ方 またありますね
知識 論理性 理性 また落ち着きが必要な作業です
意見を述べる場合は 知識
それから論理性 知識っていうのはデータをきちんと集めていること
それが論理的に集めること
それなら理性ということ
感情的にならない それに客観的に見ること
それから落ち着き あんなことは落ち着いて
淡々と述べていく 曖昧ではない明確な言葉で話すことも大事です
あれでは結構時間かかりますよ
無駄話多いんだから 喋る場合はね
それはできるだけカットして
時々繰り返す必要もありますよ
ものすごいパーっと喋っちゃうと
人の頭にみんな妄想真っ最中だからね
入らない時もありますから
まあ必要に応じて繰り返してもいいんだけど
曖昧な単語を抜けて 明確な明瞭な単語で喋る
そこまで苦労したくないと思うなら
黙ってるしかしょうがないんです
今までのプロセスで大変でしょ
そこまで苦労してこない
私は意見を言って賛同してほしいと
だったら黙っていろと
できません そんなことありえないんです
賛同してもらうということは
かなり知識的な 結構宿題をしなくちゃいけないんです
だから宿題もしないで合格しようと思ってるんだったら
もうありえない 黙った方がいいんです
知識に落ち着きに自信がない人は
徹底的に慈しみを相手に対して抱くのです
自分が勝てなくても 相手が
負けてたら負けてでいいんですよ
負けて なんて言いますか
この親がもうしょうがないと負けと言うんですかね
折れる そこでこの自分の知識にも自信がない
落ち着きも自信がない時は
相手に対して慈しみを抱く
慈しみを抱くことじゃ自尊心は倒せますよ
こいつはもうケチだからとかね
思っちゃうともうダメでしょ
もう自尊心貶してるんだから
心の中で思っても向こうはわかるんだから
だからそこは自分には論理的にピシピシと言って
もうデータを言ってお母さんどう思いますか？お母さん
この場合はどう思いますか？とか
そこはできないんだったら
まあすごい慈しみで攻撃する
徹底的に お母さんが鬼やとかね
すぐ怒るとかね そんなもう失礼なこともないで
もう大好きということで
もうお話持っていけば自分はまあ
ますよ 話は下手でデータは取ってないわ
調べてないわ ごちゃごちゃ負けるかもしれませんだけど
顔を見てると やっぱりこのこういうことやってあげましょうということに折れるんですよ
だから自分の意見に賛同した結果になるんです
私はこの子によく言うこと
本当にバカなことをいろいろやってる
ダメなさい やめなさい
ダメとか言ったって聞いてくれないでしょ
君はすごい頭がいいと思っていたのにって
それだけ すごい頭がいい賢い子だと思っていたんだけどね
私はそれにストップするんだ
残りは言いません それで終わり
私の意見に賛同してくれる
これは自尊心が込めてるだけですよ
君が頭が良くて賢い子だと私は思っていたんだよと
本人も別に嫌じゃないでしょうね
そう思ってくれるのは
だから これ今やってる我儘はやめるしかないんです
それは私が言ったからではなくて
自分自身の意見で考え方でやめてくれる
こんな微細なところですごく管理できますよ
しかし それには慈しみが必要なんです
はい また質問です 異なる意見を審判判定しなければならない時
このテーマ作る側はいろいろ考えるんですね
意見の対立が起きた時
自分の立場上 どちらか良い良い意見が裁判
審判 判定しなければならない場合
何に気をつけたら良いですか？常識であるとか
アピリオリ ルールや法律
前例に従うなどがいろいろな道具はありますが
自分の弱さにごまかされず
最善の判定ですね 下す秘訣は
だからまあ 今まで私から勉強してきたことの中でね
随分明確に頭を持ってるんですよ
だから質問が結構きちんと整理しています
はい 仏教の答え簡単ですよ
あれほど難しく考えなくても
客観的であること 各意見のメリット
デメリットを比較してみる
実行可能な意見か かと調べる
まあ大体会社とかいろんなことで
その場合の判決でしょ
だから何か実行しなくちゃあかんでしょ
別に裁判官のあれじゃないんだからね
日常生活の判定だからね
じゃあこう決めましょうということは実行しなくちゃあかんでしょ
だからそれを実行できるかないかと
そこも自分が調べる 例えば旅行にどこに行くのかと
一人が沖縄 一人は北海道にしちゃうとね
もうもう親はもう何かに決めなくちゃあかんでしょう
そういうところの場合は
各意見のメリット デメリットをちゃんと考えておいて
それから実行する場合は
どちらの方が楽に軽々くうまく実行できるのかということになったら
結果は沖縄になったと言えば
私は沖縄にしますということになるんです
で 次に 自分の立場ではなく
その組織に対して気を抜かない慈しみの念を持つ
私も社長だから 部長だから
もう課長だからとかね
親だからとか 偉そうな立場で物事を見るんじゃないんですよ
この組織も親だったら
この家庭 家族がうまくいくという
この慈しみが必要なんです
自我捨てるんですよ 課長だから決めたんじゃなくて
この課長の下に仕事をしている部下みんなうまく仕事をできるように
もうみんな幸せ 楽しくニコニコとやってほしいというね
そういうところを考えて判決を出したんですよ
そうすると間違いはない
それが秘訣です 秘訣は 4つです
これには間違いはありませんよ
もう一応お勧めますけど
実行してみてください
できれば はい 次の質問
いっぱいありますね 意見
思考性 思想 主義と暴力
意見やイデオロギーの対立が暴力
ソフトな暴力から決闘
暴力まで戦争などを引き起こすことがあるのは常識です
どうしてそこまで発展するのでしょう？どうすれば平和的な解決ができるのでしょうか
そこまで皆さんもご存知だと思いますけどね
イデオロギーの対立というのは激しいもんでしょう
今いう原理主義とかね
原理主義になるとそれほど怖いことはないんだから
キリスト教原理主義 イスラム教原理主義
あれやこれやが現れると
もうすごい怖いんですね
だからそういうのはよくわかることで
何か方法はないのかと
なんでそんなものになるのかと
じゃあ答え見てみましょう
仏教の答えは 人間は偏見持者であることは全くも知らない
こういう人々は 自分にイデオロギーがあっても
こんなのは偏見だと 人間に偏見しかないんだということは知らない
自分の思考主義が正しいと勘違いして
何も正しくないんですよ
皆の幸福ではなく 自分たちの利益のみを考える
イデオロギーの人々は自分の利益だけ考えますよ
この独裁政権とかね その場合は
独裁者が自分の利益 自分の見栄
自分の権力のみを考えるんだから
なので理性はない そういうふうに視野が狭い
心理より感情 怒り 心理より感情でしょ
怒り 高慢 見栄を重んじる
信仰している みんなそういう信仰しているのは怒り
欲 憎しみ そんなもんです
だからこういう風に世の中になっているんです
解決法というのは簡単ですよ
偏見しかないんだよって
世の中 あなたも私も それだけのことでしょう
正しくないんだと 間違ってはいたくはないんだけど
正しくはないんだと それだったら対立する必要ないでしょ
前の文章を覚えておけ
たった一行で直す問題ですよ
な パーフェクト それだけ
はい 本当に良かったと思います
これはちょっと仏教的な質問で
悪い意味での頑固 これ何でしたっけ？ディッティガーは地獄直行
それも先生のお話の中にあったのですが
悪い意味での頑固な意見
ディッティガーは間違いなく地獄に落ちる心だとお聞きしました
それはどういう仕組みなのか
意見の対立の中でどういう行為に出るのがディッティガーの特徴なのか教えてください
ディッティガーのパーリ文字だけ写して感じです
ディッティガーというのは何かの意見に固執することです
これでよくあります 仏教ではもう直行で地獄だと
これって何か聞いているんです
はい ディクティが言われる意見に固執するっていうのは
魂が創造神 死後の世界などの形而上学的な確かめる方法もない観念について何かを意見を作って
それこそが真理で 異論は全くも正しくないという
固執することがディクティガーです
これはもう暗記するしか方法ないんですよ
一応そういうこと 人間はいろんな意見を持ってますよ
今の日本は幸せか不幸かとかね
そんなのはもうなんとか確かめればいいでしょ
私は日本は幸せやとしっかり信じていますよ
だって大丈夫ですよ それで地獄に落ちません
ます でも この証拠もない
確かめる方法もない この宗教的な信仰的なこと
神は何ぞや 魂は何ぞや
あるのかないのか 死後は何ぞやと
そういうものはどうせ観念だから
頭の中で何か信じ込む
それからそれに固執する
その場合は相手の意見はどうせ捨てるんですよ
アッラーこそが神やと思っちゃうと
他の神なんかはもう邪見で
もうものすごい怖く潰さなくちゃいけないと思って
仏像がでも残してはいけません
インドにある 日本の国にある
もういろいろもう片っ端から中央アジアとかね
宗教とかのほとんど仏教の世界でしたけど
もう仏教の国でしたでしょ
トルファンと それからウイグルとかいろいろあるでしょ
今 完全にイスラム教でしょ
ひとかけらもない 昔のものは全部もうむちゃくちゃ潰せと
そういうふうになるんですよ
観念の場合 だからこの私が正しい神を信じてるとかね
知らないし 神がいるとも知らないし
ただの観念だったら 私はこの観念で
そちらはその観念でとかね
じゃあ握手して仲良くしましょうと
それでいいじゃないですか
同じ場所で教会を作って
そちらに背を向いてモスクを作る
そこで友達二人で 一人がイスラム人で一人がキリスト教で
お互いに手を繋いでいて
お互いベロベロと教会に入って
それでそれなりのやり方で祈るで
また一緒に帰ってどっかでご飯食べればいいの
どうせどちらでも観念だから証拠ないでしょ
それなんで人殺しするんですか
人の世界ってそういうことで
くだらんことで喧嘩する
具体的なことについてディクティガーにはなってしまっても
証拠を見せて意見を改めてもらうことは可能ですから
問題はありません 具体的なことについてはね
日本は絶対幸せ幸福だと頑固に信じてる人には
まあそうとも言えないんだよと色々情報を見せてあげたりとかね
日本の政府のね 経済状況やら会社の経済状況やら潰されている
もういろいろ問題あるところとかね
これこれどう思いますか？とかね
言うと まあなんとか自分の頑固さをちょっと和らげるんでしょ
客観的だから データがあるんだから
これ神の場合はもういい
だからああいう風な形而上学的な意見に固執することがディクティガー直後
そこまでのことのディクティガーはうるさいんだけど
地獄に行くっていうことはないんです
道徳と因果法則を否定することになったら
死後は地獄しか行くところありません
その邪見によって結局道徳は否定する
例えば神が全知全能で神が決めるとなんでもということになってくる
道徳を否定するんですよ
だから神を信じている人が
自分が嘘を言ってもいいやと思ってるんです
人殺してもいいやと思ってるんです
人殺さなくても 神を信じてない人たちは地獄に行っちゃう
そんなことで道徳否定するでしょう
それだったらまあ残念なことに行くところはないんです
だって因果法則 物事は原因によって成り立ちますよ
これ否定しちゃうと もう行くところがなくなっちゃうんです
そういうところでも地獄というんですよ
はい で ディクティの場合は邪見なので間違ってはいないが
正しくない方程式は当てはめないんです
ディクティ ああいう形而上学的なことについて意見持っちゃうでしょ
それが邪見という それはもう間違ってます
もうブッダの方程式使えません
私は今までずっと言った方程式はね
君の意見は間違ってはないんだけど
正しくなく正しくないんだよという方程式で調和調停はできません
意見は間違っているのです
さらに 批判は効かない
なんで批判がいるのか
その人は批判は効かないんですよ
認めない 知恵が現れる道と正反対の生き方です
それでああいう形状学的なとこを信じ込んで
他はすべて間違っていると思っちゃうと
真理の道と知恵の道と正反対なんです
効きませんということだから
私はこれを信じてるんだから
いつでも我々はもうただ必要な目がなくても
破片だけでも真理のをね
集めながら集めながら
もうどんどんどんどん膨らませていけばいいのに
だからそれはなんとかやがてたくさんの破片が集めたところで
これでは全体像ができませんよと
一応いくらかわかるでしょうと
それで六眼の目を発展すればいいでしょうし
それ土佐尊だからね 人は皆無知無明ですが
本当はそれは嫌なのです
普通で言えば どんな人でも無知で無明なんですよ
しかし これってのは嫌ですよ
無知で無明では しかし
この人は無知の高帝かなのです
この邪見の人がディッティガー派の人は無知の肯定かなんで無知でいいと信仰でいいと思っているのです
絶対的信仰やとか何とかいう
普通の人間はもう無知なんですけど
でも無知でいることを嫌がるんですね
何も修行はしていないんだけどね
知恵を開発しようと 修行していなくても
ブッダの教えを実践する気持ちは全然ないんだけど
無知だけは嫌という気分はあるんです
だが それで地獄直行じゃないんです
そっちとむそうのちょっとのことで
なぜかというと 無知は否定する
知恵があればありがたいとは思っている
何も宿題はしないんですが
だから宿題しないことはそんな大げさな問題ではないんです
宿題しないんだったら合格できないだけの話で
でも合格を否定するという意味じゃないんです
この邪見の人はこれ否定するんだから
もうどうしようもないです
そういうことで そろそろ終わったと思います
はい で それはその人の質問で
途中でまた言いたいこといっぱいあったけど
時間もないしね 一応この反対する論理方法も言えなかったんですけど
自分の意見を述べる方法と場合では同じなんですね
意見に反対する場合はね
反対する場合も同じやり方で
なぜ自分が反対するのか
そのデータきちんと整理整頓して順番に言う
では こういうことがあった場合は
あなたはどう思いますかと
どんどん言っちゃうと
相手の意見がもう潰れてるんです
で 反対したことになります
正しい ただ反対とか見てませんというのはあんまり情けない
自分の意見を述べ方 同じ述べ方ですよ
そういうことで この平和な社会
みんなと仲良くできる社会っていうのは
そういうことで築くんです
意見という一言葉からでも考えられます
それはブッダがみんなに言ってる世界です
で 話をするです どうもありがとうございます